Welcome to PyMOL 101 with Molecular Memory!
KP here, and today we’ll be learning all
about the different ways to measure the distance
between atoms in PyMOL.
Examining distances between atoms is important
because it can tell us if a potential molecular
interaction does—or doesn’t exist.
Today’s structure is 1A0o.
Let’s load it as usual and display the sequence.
This is actually segments of two interacting
proteins from bacteria, so let’s learn a
new PyMOL preset that models the interaction
of two proteins.
Action, preset, protein interface.
Nice.
Chain A, the green chain, is part of a protein
that can cause a change the movement of bacterial
flagella, and the cyan chain B is a segment
of a protein that activates the green chain.
This protein duo helps bacteria move in response
to chemical signals in their environment.
Proteins form when many amino acids undergo
dehydration reactions to link up together.
These reactions are between an amine and a
carboxylic acid.
But, because proteins are chains, one end
will have an amine that didn’t react, and
the other will have a carboxylic acid that
didn’t react.
The amine end is called the N-terminus and
the end with the unreacted carboxylic acid
is the C-terminus.
It's easy to identify these in PyMOL.
By convention, the N-terminus is listed as
the first amino acid in the chain, and the
C-terminus is last.
Let’s select these, rename them termini,
and then zoom.
Now show the termini as sticks: S, sticks.
Here’s the amine of the N-terminus, and
here’s the carboxylic acid group of the
C-terminus.
Notice in the sequence, Chain B has a bunch
of grayed out amino acids that can’t be
seen in the structure below.
Sometimes, a crystallographer will list them
because they were present in the protein that
was crystallized but didn’t show up well
enough in the crystal structure to give 3D
coordinates for.
Let’s zoom back out, and then manually zoom
in on the interface with the trackpad or mouse.
Notice amino acids near the interacting region
are automatically shown as sticks with this
preset.
Convenient.
Let’s see if there are some polar contacts:
ionic interactions and/or hydrogen bonds.
A, find, polar contacts, between chains.
And there they are.
The group of polar contacts shows up in the
names panel.
If we find the measurements distracting, we
can hide the labels, and just show the lines.
Polar contacts aren’t the only stabilizing
interactions at protein interfaces or in binding
sites.
Van der Waals interactions, like induced dipoles,
contribute as well.
And nonpolar chains cluster together in the
hydrophobic effect.
To see if these interactions are present,
we have to manually measure.
Using the dropdown Wizard menu, choose measurement.
Now we’ll manually measure between two nonpolar
side chains—ones that only contain carbon
atoms.
The measurement wizard pops up just above
the mouse control menu, and this prompt in
the upper left of the structure viewer directs
us to click on the first atom.
Let’s look for some nonpolar interactions.
Here’s a valine side chain that looks pretty
close to this isoleucine.
As long as the measurement is about 4.4 angstroms
or less, it’s likely these surfaces are
interacting.
Let’s pick the carbon on the valine that
appears to be closest to the isoleucine.
Now, we’ll measure to this carbon on isoleucine.
4.2—that’s a likely interaction.
Let’s see if there are any others.
This phenylalanine is pretty close to this
tyrosine.
Check this out, tyrosine has a polar contact—a
hydrogen bond to glutamate right here.
Because of the oxygen, it can make polar interactions.
But it’s got a big carbon ring too.
Let’s measure between these two rings.
And yup, 3.9—likely some hydrophobic clustering
going on there.
A quick way to identify whether an amino acid
side chain can make polar interactions is
to look for blue or red in the chain.
Nitrogen and oxygen are polar atoms, and can
make polar contacts.
But any side chain with a lot of carbon atoms
can make favorable van der Waals interactions
too.
The tyrosine side chain we looked at is a
great example of a side chain that can participate
in both types of interactions.
I’ll finish this lesson with a quick word
of caution.
Sometimes the more granular find polar contacts
commands don’t work as expected.
I suspect it’s the way the information is
coded in some PDB files.
But, if you don’t see any contacts at all
when selecting something like “just intra
main chain”, double check that by selecting
polar contacts “to any atoms”.
And that’s a wrap on this lesson.
Join me next time when we take a deep dive
into secondary structure and learn more about
the measurement wizard settings.